Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
All right guys, really important a story about
propaganda.
The manufacturer of consent, foreign policy
C
could not be a better example early in this
new year of how monetization policy on large
platforms like YouTube can actually help the
right beat the drums towards war.
So it's actually interesting that it's happening
so early in the new year.
Very often in the new year, monetization goes
down because a lot of advertisers spent a
lot of their money in the fourth quarter of
the previous year and often in the first and
second quarter, advertisers are more cautious
with their budgets.
They want to make sure that they save ad money
for later in 2020 so quick recap.
A lot of creators like the David Pakman show
put our videos on YouTube.
We make money when people watch the YouTube,
the YouTube videos and uh, advertisements
play.
And the primary way we make money is that
an ad plays before our video clip.
People watch the ad, we get paid, then our
clip starts.
Everybody's sort of happy.
There are guidelines for what is monetized
double.
You can't do videos about certain things and
run ads on them because they are not considered
brand safe.
And the way it was supposed to work was, you
know, over racism, violent and gory videos,
fight videos.
There were things that weren't monetized bubble
and they basically made sense.
But over the last 18 months, this has come
to really impact news and politics channels.
I have had conversations with YouTube, uh,
employees who have told me, for example, anything
on abortion is not monetized double.
Now you know, it's not a hard and fast rule
in practice.
There are many videos on YouTube about abortion,
abortion that are monetized.
Maybe they refer to abortion only tangentially.
Maybe they're super clean in their language.
Maybe the YouTube algorithm just missed it
and allowed ads to run.
But in principle, videos about abortion are
not brand safe on YouTube, but by and large,
another example, there's a someone prominent
that died recently, officially by suicide,
but some people don't believe that this person
died by suicide.
If you talk about that person, I've been told
by YouTube the video is non monetized bubble.
Even if you reference the person's name absent
any details about why they are prominent,
I think people know who I'm talking about.
If you mentioned that person's name, the video
can't be monetized.
Sometimes things slip through, but this is
at least the policy that I've been told many
of you can probably tell where I'm going with
this.
We now have one of the major stories of the
last many years, which is that our president
is starting to barrel towards a misguided
and completely backwards war against Iran.
This content is basically not monetized double
on YouTube and that is a soft way.
It's an indirect way in which demonetization
can influence the manufacturer of consent
for war with Iran and by virtue and extension
of that can influence American foreign policy
every day.
Every news channel on YouTube, corporate ones
like CNN and Fox independent ones like us
and many others, we decide what is worthy
of coverage that day.
Today's show is mostly Iran because we might
be going to war again in another incorrect
misguided war.
For political benefit, we have to cover it.
It's huge, but most of these clips are demonetized
because they refer to a current military conflict,
which is one of those areas that is vaguely
identified by YouTube as not monetized bubble.
Now I know that some of you will see ads on
some of the clips on our channel and on others.
There are clips that are slipping through
and we never really know why one is monetized
and another is not.
The algorithm is opaque.
It doesn't work perfectly, but if you are
CNN, you can either just have a different
ad deal on YouTube where you can monetize
everything.
We don't have that, we don't have that privilege,
but if you're as big as CNN or as big as Fox
news, you're so big that YouTube is a small
piece of your revenue and you don't care.
So CNN and Fox news and other corporate media,
they can cover the run up to possible war
with Iran with no serious negative repercussions.
They don't depend on YouTube revenue with
us.
When we cover what's going on with Iran, we
lose financially.
Again, if the algorithm catches us, it's still
early in the Iran thing and there are videos
that are getting through and being monetized,
but I've talked to other creators who say
I'm getting a lot of Ron's stuff demonetized
but every single day we get closer to it being
policy where YouTube says advertisers don't
want to touch the Iran war as it may one day
be.
If you talk about Iran, much like for a while,
if you talked about Syria, you get demonetized.
So it puts creators in the position of saying,
do I want to cover the right stuff today,
which is Iran or do I want to make money so
I can pay staff and connectivity and studio
rent.
We have some other revenue sources, so my
plan is to do all of the Iran coverage that
I believe makes sense and right now it's a
hell of a lot, but we are going to take a
hit.
Other shows maybe less diversified in terms
of revenue.
They may not be able to do all the Iran coverage
they think is proper and remain viable and
this is how foreign policy gets influenced.
This is how consent is manufactured.
Some of the strongest anti war in Iran voices
are independent voices who are increasingly
going to be unable to make money putting out
their content, which will influence at least
some of these voices to say, you know what,
I've got to talk about something else.
Instead of doing an hour on Iran, I'll do
15 minutes on Iran and 45 minutes about other
stuff.
This is part of the process of manufacturing
consent.
YouTube is not saying to be clear, let's the
monetize around content so that we have fewer
anti-war voices so that we go to war with
Iran.
That's not YouTube.
It's priority.
It's simply money for them, but it has the
effect of limiting independent anti-war voices
so that the predominant ones remain corporate
voices, many of which basically just cheerlead
the military industrial complex and the foreign
policy apparatus that Donald Trump represents.
So when I say, Hey, you know, you should really
fund shows that you like directly get a membership@joinedpacman.com
for a few bucks.
I'm literally saying to you, the system in
place disencouraged his disincentivizes shows
like ours and others from covering the insanity
of the beating of drums towards war with Iran
that are increasingly being hit.
When you sign up, you were saying cover what
matters, not what's monetized bubble.
That's my position on this.
That's my place in this.
So this is serious stuff and it matters hugely.
This is one of the ways a manufactured, uh,
this is one of the ways that you see consent
manufactured in media.
It limits information that is vital to people's
decision making.
If the average person who's busy living their
life, uh, wants to decide what is it that
should happen with Iran, should I be writing
my member of Congress saying, let's go get
them or should I be writing my member of Congress
saying, I will vote you out if you don't get
in the way of Donald Trump doing this.
If you have an entire wing of antiwar voices
that just lose money.
If they talk about it, you are putting an
obstacle there to present people with both
sides of the story, including I would argue
the important side, which is we're doing this
again, we just did this with Iraq in 2002
in 2003 we're really going to do the same
thing on corporate media with the same people.
Ari Fleischer and who else was it that I saw
being interviewed?
You know, other people that were saying, we've
got the evidence and Saddam is linked to nine
11 and he's got uranium and all this stuff
didn't have it.
The WMDs weren't there.
Uh, the same people are being brought onto
manufacturer consent and the soft way to disincentivize
the antiwar voices.
You know, MSNBC fired Phil Donahue when he
was the only anti-war voice in 2002, 2003
against the rack.
Now it can be done in a very different way
just by demonetizing.
People who want to talk about this conflict,
we'll keep talking about it.
My ask is support us directly by grabbing
a membership@joinpacman.com